ma question s'adresse à monsieur gérald
darmanin ministre l'action et des
comptes publics suite à l'action l
annonce faite par le gouvernement de
réduire les niches fiscales en diminuant
le plafond gaube global de ces dernières
un imposant des conditions de ressources
pour en bénéficier a faim dit vous
qu'elle profite aux classes moyennes
plutôt qu aux plus aisés la fiscalité
française est un objet de curiosité qui
amène la france au plus grand au premier
rang des prix des pays européens dont
l'impôt est le plus lourd
les deux ans que vous avez passé à bercy
n'y ont rien changé ce sont ces fameuses
niches fiscales qui permettent une
bouffée d'oxygène aux contribuables
écrasé par l'impôt aujourd'hui la crise
et gilet jaune et le besoin de
ressources supplémentaires conduit votre
gouvernement a raboté ces niches
l'objectif l'objectif étant de montrer
du doigt ces contribuables qui
bénéficient de niches fiscales et par là
même de les désigner comme des
privilégiés
soudain ces mécanismes dont on vante l
utilité emploi à domicile dons aux
associations investissements dans la
transition énergétique n'aurait plus
aucune justification
monsieur le ministre clairement vous
gérer une crise politique née d'un
ras-le-bol fiscale en créant tout
bonnement une nouvelle hausse d'impôt
encore une mesure à l'encontre des
classes moyennes 14 quand allez vous
cesser de matraques et ces français qui
travaillent payent des impôts et assure
la solidarité nationale que du choc
je m'unis monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice vous nous interroger sur la
dépense fiscale et je me dois avant tout
d'excusés gérald darmanin ni de l'action
des comptes publics qui est retenue cet
après midi vous annoncer dans votre
question le fait que nous aurions décidé
de revenir sur un certain nombre de
niches fiscales il n'en est rien aucune
décision n'a été prise
par contre il est important et
intéressant d'ouvrir ce débat la dépense
fiscale peut être un bon levier pour
promouvoir des comportements vertueux
pour mener et inciter à tel ou tel
investissement soit en matière d'emploi
sont en matière de diverses politiques
publiques
cependant force est de constater vous
pouvez faire ce constat avec nous que
l'accumulation des niches fiscales dans
le temps a amené à un démembrement de
pans entiers de notre fiscalité a mené à
une perte de lisibilité et vous avez
souligné vous-même que nous affichons
parfois des taux de prélèvement
extrêmement élevé et que dans ces cas là
les niches fiscales servent de soupape
de décompression ce qui nuit plus à la
lisibilité qu'à la simplicité du système
et enfin il ya aussi un phénomène
d'optimisation avec une superposition
niche qui permet à tel ou tel
contribuable d'être particulièrement
avantagé
même si nous pouvons noter que depuis
2008 notamment à l'initiative de gilles
carez et didier migaud déplafonnement
sont intervenus de manière successive au
bénéfice de ces niches fiscales nous
allons travailler à ce sujet avec en
tête deux impératifs
le premier impératif est de continuer ce
que nous faisons depuis le début c'est à
dire diminuer les prélèvements
obligatoires sur les ménages et en aucun
cas taxer les classes moyennes le
deuxième impératif vise à trouver plus
d'égalité car par exemple en matière
d'impôt sur le revenu
vous devez savoir et vous savez
certainement que 10 % des contribuables
les plus aisés bénéficient de 50 % des
14 milliards de niches propre au seul
impôt sur le revenu
tous les parlementaires sur tous les
bancs madame la sénatrice ont toujours
dit au fil des débats qu'il fallait
clarifier et simplifier le système des
niches fiscales et je livre à vous cette
citation que j'ai trouvé dans le journal
les échos du 9 janvier
quelqu'un disait dans les échos le 9
janvier il faut tout remettre à plat en
matière fiscalité il ya 350 en impôts et
taxes des niches fiscales partout et ça
manque de lisibilité
celui qui disait cette phrase frappé au
coin du bon sens s'appelle laurent
wauquiez
et madame claudine thomas monsieur
ministre que j'entends bien vos
arguments
quelques chiffres sur l'action de votre
gouvernement malgré tout le déficit
commercial de la france devaient battre
un record en 2019 à hauteur de 65
milliards d'euros le déficit public qui
devrait être contenue sous la barre des
3% est annoncée à 3 3% en 2010 9 et le
taux de prélèvements obligatoires que
vous estimiez à 44,3 pour cent dans la
loi de programmation à tiendra à 45 % du
pib
pas de quoi pavoiser monsieur le
ministre